take a clean sheet of paper and write
down goals in today's date and then
write down 10 goals that you would like
to accomplish in the next 12 months and
write them in the present tense almost
like you're submitting an order and just
write that i earn i achieve i weigh i
drive such and such a car i own whatever
it happens to be and the goals will be
financial goals family goals physical
goals and so on write down 10. and then
you take this list of 10
and you say if i had a magic wand and i
could wave this magic one
and i could have any one goal on my list
within 24 hours
which one goal would have the greatest
positive impact on my life
which one goal and go over it and
usually this will jump out at you and
put a circle around that goal
and that's a goal you transfer to a
clean sheet of paper and then you follow
the seven steps write it down
set a deadline right make a list of
everything you have to do to accomplish
it organize the list into a checklist
take action and then do something every
day if you'll just do this this simple
exercise then uh you'll all be rich
i'll be rich nothing nothing can stop
you but yourself
i'm going to show you the recipes and
the formulas that you can use and
sometimes it just takes one choice and
remember 87 percent
of millionaires and billionaires are
self-made they started with nothing
and nobody's smarter than you and
nobody's better than you
if somebody else can do it especially
with all the disadvantages that many
people start off with if someone else
can do it you can do it as well that's
the proof
abraham lincoln once said that some
become wealthy as proof that that all
can become wealthy so i wanted to share
with you what i call the seven seas so
the first c
is the sea of clarity clarity is my
favorite word in success it's my
favorite word in business i have done
consulting for more than a thousand
corporations large companies worldwide
companies like ibm and general motors
and pepsico and bank of america i mean
big
companies and what i found is in every
single situation
problems occur when the company becomes
unclear about what it is they're doing
or how it is they're doing it basically
it's clarity lack of clarity now here's
something else i learned and they did a
study of 50 owners of companies
successful owners of companies like
yourselves and they ask them what is the
uh very best time management
or business tool that you've ever
discovered 49 out of the 50 held up a
right a yellow writing pad
yellow writing path sort of like like
this and this is what they did this is
how they planned their day they made a
list to-do list today that is they they
wrote down everything they had to do
they always work from a list if you
don't work from a list it's very much
like taking your hands off the wheel of
your car going down a winding road in
the mountains
what happens is your life's going to go
up and you're instantly going to start
doing irrelevant and unimportant
and useless things and at the end of the
day you'll be exhausted and you'll
accomplish nothing the most powerful
tool in the world is you a pen and a
piece of paper this is the greatest
wealth creator in the world
the second c is the sea of competence
and the sea of competence says it's very
simple is that you can only earn a lot
of money if you're very good at what you
do
and so one of the most important things
you do is you break down your work into
skills
and you say what are the most important
skills i need to have to be successful
and there's recruiting is a very
important skill training is an important
skill managing motivating is an
important skill
leading supervising important skills so
what you do is you think what are the
skills that i will need to be in the top
ten percent of my field
you don't have to be in the top one
percent just be in the top 10 percent
because there are no successful people
who are not good at what they do
they are good at what they do and they
are good at what they do because they
work at it all the time whether you're
in sports or whether you're in music or
chess or anything else there's a
wonderful
study basically what it said was
studying the most successful people
is that these these people spend four
more hours becoming good at what they do
than average people the other people
don't do it and that everybody has
natural abilities but the ones who use
those abilities
transform themselves by really really
working hard at becoming good one skill
at a time this is another thing that's
really important don't try to be good
good at everything because what happens
you just break down you just overwhelm
yourself and you'll just give up you say
oh i tried that before
i had an experience which i'll pass on
to you when i was a young man i was in
my 20s and i was in sales and i was in
cold calling sales knocking on doors
every day and
i was
making one
or two sales a week i was living in a
little rooming house with a bed and a
floor
and uh
and a little bathroom and i was
struggling i could tell you within a
dollar how much money i had
in my world at that time because it was
less than a dollar
and i worked get up at five or six
o'clock in the morning i'd be waiting at
eight o'clock in the morning when people
came to work i would knock on doors
office doors and and business doors all
day long and then in the evenings i'd go
out and knock on homes and
apartments and i would make call after
call after call i made hundreds of calls
and with no sales the first year i made
more than 20 000 calls and only made a
few sales just enough to survive
and then one day
i asked a question which i'm going to
help you with as i said
of all the skills what's holding me back
more than anything else and the answer
was closing the sale
is that i
couldn't get people to make a decision
so i made a decision i still remember
the time date placed it in my little
rooming house
when i decided i was going to learn how
to become very good at closing sales and
i began to read everything i could find
i set a way for books i did everything i
could find to study the psychology and
the techniques and methods of closing
sales in one year my income went up 10
times
changed my life forever
the third c is the sea of concentration
and these are not necessarily in order
but
in in a way these are the sea of
concentration is your ability to focus
which we've talked about before it's
your ability to focus single-mindedly on
one thing at a time
and to work on that one task until it's
complete
and to discipline yourself not to do
anything else or to become distracted by
emails and bells and bips and
noises and things like that it's just
your ability to focus like a laser beam
on a single task
start and finish your most important
task number four is constraints between
where you are today
and where you want to be sometime in the
future a goal
is there is always one
constraint or choke point that
determines the speed at which you get
from here to here
that's the constraint so the art of life
is to identify the constraints that are
holding you back
from achieving
the goal that you want to achieve so you
say to yourself all right
you want to achieve a particular goal
so you ask yourself what is the one
factor that determines the speed at
which you achieve that goal
and don't try to change the world try to
change one thing one factor try to
alleviate the one factor
and that that'll change your whole life
it's unbelievable number five is
continuous learning
uh and development is dedicate yourself
to becoming better and better at what
you do it must be a part of your life
you must breathe in breathe out and
learn new things self-made millionaires
self-made billionaires spend 60 to 90
minutes every day studying their field
we need new material
uh warren buffett was just relegated
from number
three to number four
richest man in the world and warren
buffett reads 500 pages a day
he reads all the time and he's one of
the richest men in the history of the
world and he and his partners all say
the same thing you've got to read read
and learn all the time and one idea can
make you rich so just keep flooding your
mind with new ideas
number six is um
commitment there's no success without
commitment without you putting your
whole heart
into what you're doing and putting your
whole heart into what you're doing for a
long time but if you do there is no
limit on what you can accomplish you get
up in the morning and you make a
decision that by gum i am going to
succeed in this business no matter how
long it takes no matter how many hours a
day
and number seven is courage
and courage
winston churchill said courage is
rightly considered the foremost of the
virtues for upon it all others depend
and encourage what you have is two parts
the first part of courage is the courage
to begin to launch to take a chance to
face failure and rejection to try
something with a very great possibility
that you will fail and you'll feel
embarrassed and upset and your
self-esteem will go down and so on but
the second part of courage is
persistence
it's the power to keep going and keep
pushing yourself and driving yourself
a woman i was going out with before i
was married
she asked me brian she said what is your
best quality
and
i thought about that
and i think i said i said i think my
best quality is that i never give up
and i found that that's true because i
never give up and my children never give
up it's it is not in our vocabulary we
never think we'll try something
different we'll try something new we'll
take the losses and so on but we'll
never give up so how do you develop this
unshakable quality
of persistence which will guarantee your
success in life nothing can stop you if
you don't quit if you don't quit then
the only alternative is you must succeed
and eventually you must succeed greatly
well the great rule you become what you
think about but you become what you say
to yourself so what you do is you say to
yourself these magic words you say
i
never give up
if you never give up my promise to you
my guarantee to you is that you are
going to be an enormous success in the
months and years ahead and i hope you
are thank you very much